donc le gouvernement recule ça serait
bien de penser justement à ces gens qui
n'ont plus rien et que vous mettez dans
les mauvaises conditions pourquoi je dis
ça parce que l'impression que vous même
ne sais pas ce que vous voulez l'autre
jour j'ai coûtent ces news gens
attendant rudi bah moi je veux 200 euros
de plus nette par smic
après jonathan une autre chaîne nous on
veut la démission de jean dans une autre
chaîne
nous on veut que les sens ça soit plus
taxés en bref nbaa maintenant on sait
pas ce que vous voulez parce que vous
avez tellement il ya tellement de
mouvement il n'y a pas de leader que
maintenant que le gouvernement recule
quand on vous demande clairement ce que
vous voulez chaque gilet jaune à une
demande différentes et en attendant les
autres crèvent de faim parce que les
boutiques sont vides donc il ya un an
aux données pardon mais qu'est ce que
vous voulez et puis comme ça on se rend
pour apprenez décision n'est pas un cas
là mais leur procurant pourra compter
sur vous voulez vous produire l'avez
compris ce que je vais dire des loups
après malheureusement c'est je comprends
ce que vous dites mais c'est le propre
d'une d'une révolte d'une manifestation
protéiforme c'est que ça vient dans tous
les sens et aujourd'hui les français les
français sont à bout les français
craquent
on leur a tout enlevé à part leur
dignité et respect rien ne faut pas
s'étonner qu'ils foncent tête baissée
quelque part oui valérie schiste
justement après 7 parce que c'est
vraiment une reculade du gouvernement
visiblement vous avez réussi à les faire
plier off qui pourrait être considéré
comme une victoire on appelle un mot
nous en vous disant on a gagné une
première bataille c'est maintenant
l'occasion de se dire on se met tous
autour d'une table et effectivement
département par département on a
représentant des gilet jaune et on
décide de qui va aller à l'elysée
dialoguer avec les représentants du
gouvernement
c'est ça serait trop facile finalement
pour un gouvernement parce que militant
d'une main mais la main elle évite faut
qu'il tende la main pleine et la dell
vous savez moi vous savez je suis avec
vous depuis le début je joue sous je
vous soutiens beaucoup mais je pense
aussi milan à tous ces commerçants qui
prépare noël
comment ils vont faire aussi ce week end
encore je sais qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
qui disent que ils vont pas pouvoir
aller faire leurs courses de noël qui
vont essayer de commander en ligne
donc ça peut être aussi la mort de tous
les petits commerçants qu'est-ce qu'est
ce que vous dites là dessus parce que
mine de rien je pense que le
gouvernement aussi a fait 1 enfin un
moonwalk
comme jeudi reculé non mais justement
pour que ça se calme ce week-end pour
que sa puce un petit peut repartir
c'est encore faire comme si tout à
l'heure c'est en prenant des levées il
nous a pris moi mais moi pour des cons
depuis des semaines cemea des mois je
parle même pas des ddd quinquennat
précédent des gouvernements précédents
tout ça je parle juste vraiment ces
dernières semaines mais amer ça devienne
on a beau crier notre note de 2 c mais
ce coup
c'est pas juste - moi je passais moi je
moi le gouvernement voilà si vous êtes
vous et tenir des contrecoups je
comprends tout à fait moi autre français
qui ont besoin de travailler en ce
moment et qui qui voit il ya des gens
voilà qui travaille juste pendant cette
période là et qui vont se retrouver
je vous dis à mettre la clé sous la
porte sûrs qu'ils sont oui je les
comprends et je suis aussi désolé c'est
ça avoue que c'est pas trop ça ça vous
fait moi c'est ça qui me fait mal c'est
nous tous et toutes ces personnes qui
vont se retrouver vraiment dans la merde
avec tout ça le mouvement on comprend
vos revendications les comprend et tu le
sais que j'ai été un des premiers à vous
donner la parole parce que je sais que
voilà donc je bosse comme un fou et a du
mal à s'en sortir et et en a ras-le-bol
mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui il ya des
gens aussi qui disent on a on a loupé
notre saison et il vous en veulent même
pas parce qu'ils disent on est avec eux
mine de rien mais s'il pouvait nous
laisser travailler deux trois semaines
ça serait ça serait intéressant pont
puis qu'est ce t'en penses je les
comprends je suis s'est désolé j'ai mon
grand frère qu'un restaurant saracens
qu'est ce qui dit comment il fait soit
ils tapent à 10 calme-toi mérite a dit
quoi non il me dit rien mais attention
elle est tellement pris à la gorge en ce
moment qu'il est tellement concentré par
son travail
ouais mais en fait ce qui se passe c'est
que les gens ils disent maintenant perdu
pour perdu même si la saison perdu voilà
bon bah on va on va essayer de faire
avancer les choses c'est ça que tu dis
on essaye mais tu peux pas parce que on
parle on parle vraiment je te le dis ce
week-end il ya beaucoup de gens qui
disent que les ministres parlent de
violence sans limite
voilà en ce moment et que samedi on
parle de balade on parle on parle de
vraiment d'événements qui peuvent faire
peur à tous les français est-ce que même
toi t'as pas peur moi j'ai peur aux à
ses vues même les jaunes comme moi
j'aime ça on voit de façon de samedi en
samedi c'est en crescendo mais oh mais
ce classement grâce samedi dernier la
l'apocalypse que c'est bien sûr il
paraît que ça veut dire mais ce que toi
tu me concerne je cautionne ça tu peux
pas du tout quelle personne sensée que
s'adresse à moi tu vois le fond je pense
être arrêté à peu près équilibré de fait
une personne a même l'équilibré ouest
grand je cautionne pas ça donc ouais
mais quand tu dis ça va être encore plus
chaud samedi
je le déplore mais c'est inévitable
malheureusement c est ce qu a pas
d'autres moyens de se faire entendre ce
que déjà vous êtes sûrs autant dont vous
avez fait quand même en amont on
aimerait bien ça fait parce que les
semaines qu'on nous dit oui mais il ya
d'autres moyens que des blocages que
ceux-ci que cela parce que c'est des
personnes qu'on est comme une
proposition concrète pour qu'on se fasse
entendre et qu'on soit réellement
crédible est vraiment que le message
soit reçu par le par l'elysée qu'est ce
que vous envisagez justement des
élections par département pour avoir des
représentants entre guînes officiel
qu'ils puissent dialoguer non mais y a
des il ya des choses qu'il ya des choses
qui se prépare en bas ça s'était passé
c'est un peu technique ce que veulent
savoir ce qui va se passer samedi